hey what's up everybody it's Warren and
today I want to talk about a question
that a lot of people have been wondering
about since Infinity Ward came out and
that question is why didn't Doctor
Strange cut the Infinity Gauntlet off of
Thanos by opening and closing a portal
on his arm so why didn't he do this to
Thanos and just cut the Infinity
Gauntlet off of his arm well as it turns
out the Russo brothers kind of gave us a
reason to why Doctor Strange just
couldn't do this quick reminder about my
give away giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet to enter all you have
to do is be a subscriber like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
to start off you have to keep in mind
that the Russo brothers who are the
directors of infinity war and Avengers
in game made Thanos the way that they
wanted to make him they have stated
several times that yes they draw
inspiration from the comics but they
don't do everything the exact same way
because then we would just know
everything there would be no point to
the movies because we would know
everything that is going to happen so
the Russo brothers version of fan o's in
the MCU is exactly what they wanted him
to be they even changed his origin story
in the MCU and in an interview that the
Russo brothers did a while ago while
they were explaining his origin they
actually explained why Doctor Strange
couldn't just cut the Infinity Gauntlet
off of Thanos his arm here's what Joe
Russo had to say in the interview Thanos
is this virtually indestructible
character who's stronger than the Hulk
and has invincible skin he's from a
planet called Titan many years prior to
the film his planet was experiencing a
cataclysmic shift they were running out
of resources and they were overpopulated
Thanos made a recommendation that they
exterminate half the population randomly
in order to save the rest of the
population of course the Titans rejected
his notion branded him a madman exiled
him and the planet ended up dying so he
has taken it upon himself to go planet
by planet throughout the universe and
wipe out half of the population of each
planet as a way to correct the planet
and bring it back into balance did you
catch the very first line of what Joe
Russo said about Thanos
he said vanos is this virtually
indestructible character who
stronger than the Hulk and has
invincible skin so if Thanos is
indestructible and has invincible skin
nothing could cut through it and if you
look back to the scenes on Titan in
infinity war Thanos got hit with a lot
and was barely even faced Tony dropped
that giant chunk of metal on him in the
beginning of the scene nebula hit him
with her ship and Tony fired a bunch of
missiles at him none of which hurt him
at all Tony finally managed to give him
a little tiny scratch on his face but
judging from the fact that after all the
attacks that he took he was barely
scratched and the Risser brother said
his skin was invincible trying to cut
the Infinity Gauntlet off of his arm
when at work and not to mention that dr.
strange probably tried it at one point
in time going through his fourteen
million different scenarios and it
didn't work which is why he didn't do it
in Avengers infinity war so there are
really two reasons why dr. strange
didn't try and cut the Infinity Gauntlet
alpha Thanos and Avengers infinity war
one is because the Russo brothers made
Thanos indestructible and invincible in
Avengers infinity war and two is he
actually probably did try it and failed
during one of his fourteen million
different scenarios we just didn't see
it on-screen so that's why we didn't see
dr. strange try and cut the Infinity
Gauntlet alpha Thanos is armed with the
portal and Avengers Infinity Ward let me
know what you all think about this and
what you think about what the Russo
brothers said about Thanos being
indestructible and invincible let me
know in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers in game
as always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]